(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Much like today's birds,
pterosaurs ruled Earth's Mesozoic skies.
(pterosaur cawing)
Adapting to many different habitats
while their dinosaur cousins roamed below.
But these were no birds.
Pterosaurs were flying reptiles,
and some were as big as fighter jets.
Pterosaurs means winged lizard in Greek,
and they were the very
first vertebrates on Earth
to take to the skies.
The most well-known pterosaur
is the pterodactycl.
It was the first one discovered
back in the 18th century,
but since then,
paleontologists have uncovered
more than 200 different
species, including pteranodons,
which were quite large,
and quetzalcoatlus,
one of the most massive pterosaurs of all.
Named for the Aztec winged serpent god,
quetzalcoatlus had a
wingspan of nearly 40',
and likely soared through the skies,
hunting for baby dinosaurs below.
Some, like anurognathus,
were the size of small birds,
and probably preferred to eat insects.
With such a wide range in pterosaur size,
there is ongoing debate
over how some species
were able to fly, but similarities
in their wing structure
and anatomy may offer clues.
Pterosaur wings ran along their sides
from shoulder to ankle,
and each wing was held up
and supported by an elongated digit.
The first pterosaur ever discovered
was actually named for
this characteristic.
Pterodactyl is a combination
of the Greek words
for wing and finger.
Each pterosaur wing
consisted of a tough membrane
laced with blood vessels,
fibrous cords, and muscles,
and it has been theorized that the muscles
could alter the shape of
their wings in mid-flight,
the same way a passenger
jet might adjust its wings
during takeoff and landing.
Pterosaur fossils also suggest
that even the largest species
must've been relatively
light for their size,
because, much like birds,
their bones were hollow.
Hollow bones would've enabled
even quetzalcoatlus to soar.
But, not all pterosaurs could fly.
In 2009, paleontologists
found an enormous specimen
in Transylvania that
they nicknamed Dracula.
At 11.5' tall, with a wingspan of 39',
it's one of the largest
pterosaurs ever found.
But, the shape of its shoulders and wings
suggest it probably
couldn't get off the ground.
With every new discovery,
paleontologists are learning more
about the nature of pterosaurs.
But, the hollow bones
that enabled some of the
largest pterosaurs to fly
are also part of the reason
their fossils are so often incomplete.
And, the full picture of a
sky once ruled by reptiles
has yet to be revealed.